[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to our
webinar today the gdn boot camp getting
started with the Google Display Network
in this hour you're going to learn how
to start placing pay-per-click ads on
the Google Display Network with an
inventory of more than 2 million
websites and apps the Google Display
Network gives you endless targeting
options available to reach users if you
know what you're doing well in today's
webinar Google PPC expert brad geddes
will explain all the targeting methods
used for the Display Network and will
give you an overview of the
possibilities then we're going to walk
you through the most effective ways to
start advertising across the Display
Network I really am looking forward to
hand this off to our guest our expert
Brad Guetta's he's the author of
advanced google adwords he's a
co-founder of the award-winning company
a dallas an automatic platform for
testing and PPC recommendation and brian
frequently writes columns for search
engine land he code moderates the
adwords forum on webmaster world
he's a course advisor for the digital
marketing curriculum at simply learned
and it's a pleasure to have him talking
about something a little bit different
the Google Display Network
so welcome Brad thanks for joining us
hey thanks standing so welcome everyone
and today we're going to go over
starting with the Google Display Network
so we're going to briefly take a look at
what is it just to make sure we're all
on the same page with what it is and
then we're going to look at some of the
targeting types we'll go through
remarketing and how to make remarketing
lists and get started through marketing
campaigns from there we'll move into the
ads are going to be displayed and then
he'll would expand with some in market
and similar audiences so first off and
we say what's the Google Display Network
so it's a collection of three million
sites and apps where ads can be shown so
it's not searched any longer right with
search someone's actively looking for
you with display you're often attracting
them away from the content they're
engaged with video other texts are paid
so forth
to the largest of the display partners
are owned by Google YouTube and Gmail
but there's a lot of others wthr.com
ascom New York Times etc are all display
partners and we think about Reach
right it's 90% of all Internet users and
it serves over a trillion impressions
per day so it's a pretty large place to
serve ads so we have to think about that
the type of targeting we really want to
get into so we're going to spend most of
our time today on audience targeting but
we're going to just make sure we define
these three types and sort of look at
how these fit in the funnel so audiences
are based upon first party data is what
we're going to talk up primarily today
and we'll cover first versus third party
data this is where you're marketing to
users based on behavioral data or
similar characteristics of that user
base so you're marketing to the person's
attributes not necessarily the site
itself
now contextual is different contextual
derived from content right is based upon
what that pages data is or similar pages
users have been to very recently and
then finally the third option is you can
choose individual websites apps
placements videos where you want your
ads to appear so I'll search is often
thought of it is as much at the bottom
of the funnel we think about display we
really want to look at the funnel and
say where are we trying to reach users
where are we trying to introduce our
Brande users or that's going to be a lot
of the affinity audiences similar
audiences and taking large placement
sites and today we're going to cover the
similar audiences we need to
consideration right when someone's
learning and shopping let's end market
and custom audiences and you can pick
review sites right for placements when
someone's down ready to buy that's
remarketing we're getting into first and
then retention as custom ads which is
audience data based upon your CRM data
so today we're primarily going to focus
on remarketing and then similar to
remarketing and then again is some of
the end marketing custom so we say well
what what exactly is an audience right
so when audience is a collection of
users who share similar characteristics
or behaviors so for instance if someone
came to your website added something to
your shopping cart and then left right
there characteristic is they've added
someone shopping cart and abandon that
process that's remarketing because it's
based on your website behavior right
people just came to your website that's
all you share characteristic of being on
your website I give us behavioural
people who are currently shopping for a
new car now you may not know that
information right you don't know and
tell someone's been on your site and
they've looked at your auto modes
your your cars and in automotive offers
that they're shopping so that's
third-party data where Google looks at
who has recently been looking at
comparing cars and prices and
dealerships and so that's like an in
market audience they share
characteristics of currently researching
cars but not so in your site now we have
others like affinity so users they
long-term interest in photography so
they may not be looking to buy a camera
today right but they've got this
long-term interest every once in a while
they look at you know how to make better
photographs and in different ways of
f-stops and how to change their
photography settings on a camera and so
they're a great one if you're
introducing a new product to you just
want to get the word out and then we've
got people with similar characteristics
people who are similar to those who
convert on your website so audiences can
cover a lot of range of their behaviors
so we get into audiences we also have to
think about this first versus third
party data so first party data means
it's your information you
created the targeting method based upon
information on assets you control so
with customer match but this is first
party data that comes from your website
or your CRM system right so remarketing
is behavioral data based upon your
assets based upon your website right so
first party means it's your information
now third party data means it's
aggregated from another party so it's in
this case we're how about using Google's
data so it would be similar audiences or
in-market audiences where you can still
market based upon this third party
audience data it just doesn't happen to
be yours now while there's all these
options across display and there's three
trillion impressions right there's the
Trilly impressions a day we don't want
all of those right we want to start with
what's going to make us money first and
then expand so that's what we often
start with remarketing and so
remarketing is marketing back to users
who have already interacted with your
website there's a few reasons we want to
solve remarketing one is is when we look
at the customer journey right Nielsen
says customers visit websites at least
six times on average in the overall
purchase process now that may not just
be retail that includes finances and
travel and form fills and insurance Lee
Genesis in retail where consumers
consult 10 sources of information and
90% will switch the device before making
a purchase so if you're thinking about
just search right that's a touch point
maybe they came back to you a second or
third time even on search right that's
two or three touch points that's half or
a third right of what the average person
is before buying so often what this
remarketing is is that reminder or to
come back and finish something a people
who say
people abandon a shopping cart 75% said
they intend on returning to make a
purchase
now intention and action are completely
different what I have bookmarks from 10
years ago of sites I intended to go back
to I probably never have looked at half
those bookmarks before but through there
it's an intention right so that
remarketing ad is saying yet we know you
want to go back here's your reminder to
actually do it
so this is a big change what's happened
over time is the amount of touch points
that exist before conversion so this is
a retailer I've worked with fur I don't
know 15 years or something and so we
took six months of data from a few years
ago which is in blue and said how many
times is a person that visit your
website before they convert and you know
few years ago it was almost 45% of
people were one touch and almost no one
was six or more touches or that was a
very rare and then we looked at the
exact same data exact same website a few
years later and said well now how often
is it taking some to convert and the
trend line is the increase or decrease
right and number of visible for
conversion and what we see is lower on
right that one two three touch points
it's actually decreased for one in two
and then we look at three four five six
seven even twelve plus touch points
right that's what that big increase is
coming from and so what we're really
looking at these days is consumers look
more before buying and in some cases
it's not that they look more it's that
we can now measure it right in you know
10 years ago someone wasn't going to
YouTube to watch TV they were watching
TV on television right and you couldn't
track that along with your digital data
well now what they're watching on
YouTube or Netflix or Hulu so forth you
can track that back to your websites
we've added a lot of touch points we can
also measure we couldn't before so we
think about right remarketing that's our
first party data it's one of the best to
start with because it really is that
reminder to convert the users been to
your site they know the offer they know
what they're getting into so when they
click on an ad to go back to your site
there's no surprise involved right
they've said okay I've been to the site
right I understand what that offer is
and yeah I'm ready to do something and
so that remarketing ad is
a pre-qualified user because the user
already understands the brand experience
so we're marketing the very first step
is well it's behavioral data based on a
website behavior so you have to collect
the behavior so we have two options for
how we want to collect this we can
install Google Analytics and we can
define our data within Google Analytics
or you can use the Google ads tag so if
you go into your account you go down
your audience data right and you've got
Google Analytics attached to your
account right you'll see your data right
there and if you have an attached that
you'll see a spot to attach Google
Analytics to your account and then
you're going to find your data within
Google Analytics if you don't use Google
Analytics your core metrics or an Adobe
analytic shop right then you're going to
use the Google ads tag often on your
site so step one is just getting your
site tagged whether it's Google
Analytics or the Google ads tag
second step is the finding your list now
personally for list definitions
I prefer google analytics because you
can be really really custom with your
lists so you're going to go into your
admin section go down an audience is
click on the button plus new audiences
and Google even suggest them for you and
create your list so it's fairly simple
to get for a get started by just going
into your admin audience data and then
click a new audience and then you define
write who should be added to the list so
for instance in this case we're just
saying if someone got to a page it says
thank you put them in the list right you
could make a list that's everybody who
went to your website it could be someone
who got to stage one of your form and
abandon your website people who spent
three minutes on your website so the
lists possibilities are are huge they're
endless which is often why we want to
start with some real simple lists of
people who went to our site people who
started to convert and didn't finish and
people who converted write some real
simple areas but to just give you an
example of how complex you can get in
this right just to seed some future
thoughts yet we work with a company who
runs a lot of TV commercials and with
television commercials most people go to
your website within zero seconds to
thirty minutes of a commercial airing in
the 30 minute delay is because of our
time lapse watching where someone's
watching you know 20 minutes behind so I
have to watch commercials and and
they'll skip over some and still you
know go to some websites and so they
keep a list of their flight schedules
where they'll make a remark enlist
that's only if someone came to their
website from the market where the
commercials are being aired within zero
minutes to 30 minutes after the
commercial airing and put them in a
specific list because that way they know
in the remarketing
they're going to use the imagery from
the TV commercial right and and that's
fairly complex setup but that's how
creative you can be with analytics
caption so we think about using our list
right it's a fairly straightforward
process we're for using Google Analytics
we install Google Analytics we go into
our Google Ads account under linked
accounts and we connect it to our Google
ads we go back to Google Analytics in
the admin section and then define our
lists and then lastly right we add users
to the ad group which we'll get to in a
minute now if you're in Google Ads
you're going to install the Google ads
tag and then you'll define your
audiences in the Google ad section in
the audience data and then you're going
to add a list to those ID groups now the
last part of list creation is duration
how long should a user be and a list a a
standard timeframe is 30 days right
let's let everyone who went to our site
for 30 days see remarketing ads if
you're an industry where it takes users
90 days you're a lot of b2b stuff it
takes a long time for user that really
convert or look at offers you can
increase your list 90 days if you're in
an industry where people convert either
really fast or they don't convert at all
then you may make a duration of three to
seven days so some common lists to start
with right is all visitors to your
website form abandoners which means they
started converting but then stopped and
then all your converters because a list
can be negative you could say I want to
reach everyone to abandon the form so
they added some of their cart went to
checkout or they went to page one of
your three page form and they started it
and then you may make converters right
people who actually finished it a
negative list you're only marketing to
people who started but didn't actually
finish now you can get much more
advanced right you could say
product viewers only people who run our
blog on people who shared our blog um we
you could make things another common one
is you can do some audience definitions
in Facebook and LinkedIn you can't do in
Google Ads so some people will use
Facebook with some characteristics on it
right to send it traffic to the site
puts the users from Facebook based upon
those characteristics and a list and
then use that with Google Ads
to remarket to them across places will
be on Facebook so start simple right
visitors abandoners converters easy way
to start a lot of expansion you can do
now if you have a structured data site
with a lot of products a large
e-commerce site a job site a travel site
they all use structured data you could
use dynamic remarketing which a lot of
the steps are similar there's just a
little bit of difference in how the ads
are rendered dynamic remarketing the
user for the ad is going to see the
products they viewed on the website so
if someone went to your site looking for
a new job your career site and they
looked at three individual jobs and you
give a feed to Google of the structured
data then the ads will actually be the
jobs they saw same with with merchants
you've probably seen ads across the web
with the ad includes the products you
viewed on our website that's dynamic
remarketing so dynamic you can use your
Google Merchant Center account to set
this up and it's fairly straightforward
so the question then is how do we
segment our websites to determine what
list to use ok so it's easy to start
with visitors abandoners converters but
sometimes you want to be more specific
right so in this case this is a
remodeling company based in Chicago home
service company right because almost all
web sites are homepage category
correct form fill checkout it just may
be the form fill happens to be a form
contact and then Yuri Thank You page so
you know they can make one list that's
remodeling options a different list
that's room additions a different list
for outside things fences and roofs and
so forth or they could get more specific
they can make a list just for kitchen
remodeling just for bath remodeling just
for basement remodeling and be even more
specific
so when you're thinking about your
segmentations you must have a hundred
active users and a list for display ad
to be shown so if each of their
categories gets twenty visits a month
they could not make every every one of
these or they would need to have a
five-month write duration and after you
know month one they're 20 users month
two forty etc before that list goes live
now that's probably too long right to
have a five month duration of someone's
looking at at you know putting up a
fence or doing some interior painting so
if you have you a hundred visitors per
category per month or at you know ten
thousand a higher number right then you
can get more specific so awesome what
you're going to do is you're going to
open your analytic system if it's Google
Analytics this is super easy a different
one you can still do this and list out
here's the audiences we want to make and
then in your analytics pick the
timeframe for how long you think the
cookie should last so if you think it's
a 38 cookie just look at last month for
inter analytics and then go to your page
you section and say all right how many
people visit the pages that we will put
in that list if that number is under a
hundred you want to either expand
timeframe or expand how many the pages
that are cooking here if it's well over
a hundred you can go ahead and make that
list now with the second site it's an
e-commerce site so we could say well
they're ecommerce site they primarily
sell cups
napkins right and in ribbon so we could
make all visitor a cup and napkin a
ribbon and a Carter banner - thank you
five lists and be done but again that's
going to make it so that we're just
showing a cup add to someone who wants a
logo or a picture or a frosted cup or a
hard side plastic cup right in our ad is
not going to be that specific to what I
usually looked for so we can say okay we
should go down another category and do
logo napkins versus personalized napkins
and logo customers personalized cups and
that makes your list get a little larger
say oh we want to go down to the the
individual product level well now the
list just went from about nine to
several hundred so as soon as your lists
expand that quickly you want to use
dynamic remarketing instead so if you're
starting to look at your site you see
five or six even two or three right good
list you don't want for about dynamic
its when you're looking at segmentation
some of the numbers jump up considerably
but dynamic is probably a better option
so then we create our lists we import
those lists to Google Ads and then we
just click create campaign pick display
create an ad group with your done before
then in our ad group targeting right oh
we're going to see is a list of all the
audiences we have right just like adding
keywords but instead of main keywords
will be audiences you select those add
them to the ad group click Save and now
you've got an ad group with an audience
in it so then the next part is we need
to have an ad for the audience so let's
get into making display ads so there
there's two types of common display ads
you have responsive and you have image
with responsive ads you give Google a
set of assets which we're going to look
at on the next slide and then Google is
going to combine those assets together
to show the ad so this means your ad can
show in any size rendering it doesn't
matter if it's a skyscraper or a banner
or square
right Google render it for you from
those assets disadvantage some of the
ads don't look that good some are only
taxed there's no image so you don't have
as much brand control over the ad but
it's very easy to essentially have your
ad shown in any ad format with very
little work or we can do image ads now
as soon as we make an image ad we have
to make an image ad for every size if
you want to test images we now have to
make multiple images in multiple sizes
to do some testing one more work to of
images but you have full brand control
so that's really that the question right
if you have a a brand department or you
have a group that always looks over your
ads or you're in a regulated industry
where you must have a copy of every ad
that served an impression you're
probably no more images if right you're
just like we don't have a lot of assets
we don't have a brand manager we're a
smaller company we just want to get
something going then use responsive so
we then and there I'd Europe right go
the ads tab we click on create new ad we
choose a responsive option and then
we're going to see write a way to set up
the ads within Google ads so first
you're going to pick your final your
route where does the user go and then
you're going to pick two images now if
you have images you can upload that fit
their their model a 4-1 and a 1-1 you
can upload your own images right in the
interface easy to use if you don't when
you click on the Edit icon that pencil
you can search Google's library and use
their images now their images are stock
they look stock everyone can pick out a
stock image it's free to use it's right
there so anyone can do it but if you
have your own imagery it's better to use
then you're going to pick your logo most
people have their logo on a 4 X 1 format
which is perfect
you also want to add the one by one
rendering it's optional you don't have
to add it but if you don't add it you
won't show in native ad formats so it's
best to use all for the landscape and
the square image and logos you can add
videos if you want to then you add your
headlines so the response meaning
Google's going to render the ads in four
ways and try to learn which one to serve
so you can add five short headlines
right and then you can make one long
headline headlines longer short never
show together
only one headlines ever displayed at
once so it is okay to duplicate
information in different headlines or
use the same information you sort have
one Anja long headline that's not a
problem below that you will see the
option to make a description a headline
and a description can show together so
you really don't want to duplicate data
from your headline to your description
and then you have the option of picking
a call-to-action button and a little
more things but it really does not take
long to make those responsive ads before
you save it you can see previews so
across the display network YouTube Gmail
for mobile or computers you can scroll
through the primary formats how your ads
are going to be rendered and say I don't
like that one and you can do some tweaks
to how the text or the images are or if
you're happy enough like they'll be some
renderings you're like that's not really
good looking but it's not really you
know against our brain it's not we're
trying to fix it because we'd have to
switch the images you'll accept it
except some of those but you can preview
your ads right make sure you're happy
with how things look or you even send
this off right to a client you can get a
link on the TV to review first save it
and now you can be showing our marketing
ads so that once we start remarketing we
collect some data we get some
conversions we're happy with it right
then our next step is usually to start
expanding our audiences expand our
Display Network presence so if we go
right back to our targeting option and
we usually want to make this in a new ad
group so just in your display campaign
click in a plus new ad group create an
ad group good your audiences then right
we can say who else you want to target
so under browse there's three options we
have affinity and custom affinity these
are some of these are going to be
combined later this year and those be
custom audience and then in market
audience you don't have to deal with
some of these these variations but in
general affinity is a long-term right
involvement with a product or service so
people who are frequent travelers are
Finity they like to travel they may not
be planning something right now and then
we have in market right in market means
they're currently researching one of
those products and then you've got you
know lastly remarketing similar
audiences off your marketing which we're
going to touch on a second so if you're
looking for users to introduce a product
to who are a long-term user of something
that's what affinity is for if you're a
performance marketer and you're just
really getting into display you should
skip it for now and move to the in
market so with in market you can do a
search across the in markets and see
it's one hundred and sixty-seven or so
categories of all the different ways
people are currently searching or buying
something
these range from B to C - to b2b areas a
lot of them expand you can autos &
vehicles expands to SUVs versus luxury
products versus trucks etc so you can
get pretty specific in the end market
now they don't know your brand so
they're not going to convert what as
well as remarketing is however these are
people who are actively looking they
just may not know you exist
so they are a good group
often introduce your brand too and then
lastly where we can really get into
defining a lot of characteristics is
custom intent so this is again probably
going to be custom later this year it's
going to be the overall same definition
process where we can define URL
someone's been to a product saved looked
for right in and then create an audience
again this is third-party data based
upon right sites they've been two types
of things they've searched for looked at
or sown interest in just show ads to
that group of users now then as you add
criteria on the side you're going to see
an idea of how many impressions you can
get for wheat per week we're in 19
countries so this is across 19 countries
when we look at it if we're only in one
this that'll be much smaller then you
get an idea some demographic some age
and gender and potentially income level
depending on where you live of that
custom intent group and if you're happy
with it you can save the custom intent
and then make an ad group for it now
with things like custom intent and in
market an affinity audiences and
remarketing even if your ad is going to
be the same for all the audience types
it's generally best to put them into
different ad groups and sometimes even
campaigns that way if you've added five
custom intents and full remarketing you
know types you can really look at the ad
group level the difference in CPA the
difference in in impressions set your
bids you can set a bit at the audience
level so you can still bid by audience
but it's easier to sort of see your data
over time and the reason some people
will do it by campaign is to control
budgets by campaign remarketing is
generally your most profitable so they
may have a very high budget for
remarketing but in market
custom intense right usually aren't
quite as profitable if they're in the
same campaign they all share the same
budget so custom intent could serve so
much your marketing ad doesn't serve as
much as it could so that's why if you're
if you start to expand quite a bit it is
useful to do them by campaign from a
budget standpoint now then once you've
been wanting remarketing in market
custom intent so forth for a while
you'll start to see similar lists pop up
in your account so these are users who
are similar to a list that you are
running so if your user list is all
users and you have a very large wide
variety audience you somewhat list it
may not be that useful if you have a
list of only people who converted and
you're a fairly niche website so it's a
really specific person your soul lists
are probably going to be fantastic to
use so they're similar to your list if
your list is very broad then your
similar list is going to be even broader
right it's similar people who have ever
been to your website can be pretty broad
if it's only people who have gone to a
product page and you're a specific
retailer or your lead generate you're in
car insurance that can be much narrower
and be a much better user base so we
like similar a lot we use it personally
quite a bit but we don't generally use
it off of everyone who's been to our
blog that's a very broad audience
instead we'll use it for people who are
subscribers I'm users who abandon the
shopping cart because they got that far
and they can be incredibly good lists to
use so what happens then right as we're
expanding remarketing we're really
moving up the funnel so remarketing more
bi-phase on my circle got moved and then
consideration we're in market a little
broader and then affinity audiences
similar audiences so forth even further
up the funnel
so remarketing is a good one because
that's that searches by base right and
remarks is that really good first step
since it is a buy based audience and
then removing up the funnel now the
Display Network is massive great okay by
Brad I just want to want to interrupt
for a second here just that one person
asking actually a couple people have
asked the same question here now that
seems appropriate talking about this at
the moment but would you get more
engagement with remark in remarketing
ads using your marketing ads with a
video I think that so we've had two
questions about people asking about the
effective video in remarketing oh sure
okay so that's a great question so let's
go back here real quick so you can add
videos to your ads if this ad is going
to be shown in an app probably never
going to be displayed if it's shown on a
website maybe you may or may not be
displayed now so for remarketing that is
not on YouTube adding video may help
some but they're not always going to be
displayed you can do remarketing purely
on YouTube which of course you can sort
of add or a video and your videos are
definitely going to be shown on YouTube
so when we look at our our previews
right you can see the YouTube specific
preview which is not clicked over be won
over over on our arch our screen here so
videos useful ad for for your general
display but they're not going to be
shown that often and for YouTube super
useful of course to use on YouTube again
in Gmail they're not going to be
displayed so that the video options
worthwhile for desktop users to add one
or two if you're really happy with them
imperative to use them if you're going
to run remarking across YouTube
properties so and with YouTube
I'm just going to expand on this real
quick we'll jump back to where you were
when you remarked it you can actually
choose only only do remarketing on
YouTube when you do remarketing on
YouTube you can do even custom lists off
of that if people who watched your
YouTube videos or users who watched at
least 30 seconds of a YouTube video and
so if you're doing either a largest
organic YouTube or you're doing
marketing on YouTube you can make custom
lists that you can actually use across
the Display Network based upon that
YouTube interaction as well that answer
that question yeah it definitely seems
to we have we have another question
coming in but we can probably save this
for a little bit later so we can have
you go beyond this here but it's like
some minutes left then we'll get into
all of our good questions yeah okay
great so so barrel through and and we've
got a lot of interest with people
chiming in with a specific question so
yes all right onward and upward all
right so the wings talked about three
million websites and apps right some of
those are going to be bad for a lot of
people some are going to be really good
for one company and really bad for
another company right and so we also
want to control our ad serving and say
wow that's just not a good placement for
me so in your accounts when you go down
to the placements data and you click
over to where ads showed this is going
to tell you the actual URLs websites etc
where your ads were displayed so when we
talk often inserts about examining query
data right to say oh if a search query
has more than 150 clicks no conversions
we may not want to make a negative
keyword right some some basic rules same
thing applies to where ads showed we
often are looking for sites or apps
where we have a lot of spin but not a
lot of conversions and so we can look at
our CPAs on our Kahn's data and
conversion data to say wow that's a lot
of spend not enough conversions and just
like
let's select them and exclude them if we
really like a site we can even select it
and add it as a site and even a just
[ __ ] for a site to show more or less
muscle it excite so same as when you're
running keywords you look at your query
data to find new keywords or find
negative keywords for anything across
Display Network we're going to look at
our placement data where ads showed is
the same as search queries right create
our filters to say if site is you know
doing X we want to make it a negative
which is called an exclusion on Display
Network and stop our ads there so that
same workflow applies now what is
important though is the brand protection
items
so again Display Network includes mature
audiences it includes game sites it
includes Park domains there are several
types of content excludes so you can go
to your account or any of your account
level data or any one of your campaigns
you'll see excluded types and labels
where you can say okay I don't want to
be shown on this type of content and you
can exclude content types so that way if
you're selling you know Disney World
tickets you probably don't want to be
shown a mature audience sites probably
not a good one for you right and choose
how to do this so this is primarily
brand protection items as keeping your
content off of certain types of sites so
just a quick recap right if the display
that works huge I mean it's three
million sites and a trillion daily
impressions so it's not that you can't
get inventory there it's really about
controlling I cross those trillion
oppressions who you really want to serve
an ad to right so with remarketing this
is often the reminder to convert it's
behavioral targeting I mean everyone who
says oh we're doing behavioral marketing
if you're dealing remarketing with
Google Ads you're doing behavioral
targeting and the key to getting that
right
is segmenting your website into
appropriate lists right just like we
think of search ad groups small groups
of keywords highly related with them
highly related at same thing applies to
your list what are the user do on your
site where they're looking for why do
different types of users go to your site
right those should be specific lists
with an ad group with a specific ad that
talks about the reason they were there
and why they should come back and
complete an action so with display ads
we can do images which means we must
create multiple sizes but we have full
brain control we can make responsive
they can show anywhere but we have less
control but you want to make sure that
you have complete ads meaning you're
wanting two logos two images a short
headline a long headline in a
description etc then we think of
expanding display we're also going to
start with in market because they're
currently researching products right
then we may branch out into similar
audiences or the custom intent audiences
and then don't forget to look at the
where ads show data to block placements
that are underperforming and then use
the content exclusions right from
placement protection
all right now rest of questions Daniel
what you chime in here here's one that
would just ask this how do you exclude
bounce or session durations below ten
seconds in remarketing and also how do
you figure out what's the best page to
send audiences to for example if you
have a visited product page audience do
you send them to the home page or to the
product page that yeah pretty clear okay
yes yes so so let's take the second one
is that's super easy if you're using
dynamic remarketing the URL the user
clicks on will be that product but it's
you want to bring them back
overall back to that offer if it's a
product put them back on that product on
maybe category if you're not doing
individual products it's more category
based if someone downloaded a white
paper on your website and you put them
in a list and a side download a white
paper you really want them to take a
trial put them to your take a trial page
and here's what we start right so again
usually a page specific for that list it
doesn't you have to make a page for that
for the list specifically but what what
page would they expect to see after
banging site previously right to get
re-engaged quickly now for the bounce
question that's a great question so
first off a bounce in Google Analytics
is a one page page view or a page view
until an event occurs so that last part
super important in it when an event
occurs so if in Google Analytics you
program an event to occur after ten
seconds it doesn't have to do anything
you say hey GA after ten seconds fire
event called still here right then right
in your list you can define that only
include users where the event still here
was triggered and that would make it so
that you would no longer be remarketing
people who came to your site less than
less than 10 seconds so because doing an
on bounce is tricky because if someone
gets your offer page and reads for five
minutes and then leaves they're
technically about
we're a one page page view so that's why
coding in an event that doesn't have to
do anything but just trigger some words
hey user has not balanced whatever will
let you only include make an all visit a
list but it's really we call it an all
engaged visitor list and we cut out the
the people usually less than about
thirty seconds or so with a wide
variance in the quality of publishers
what's the best way to identify and
remove low-quality publishers and get
more impact from KY quality publishers
on a network so this depends on how
aggressive you want to be so we you know
you can you can go into your Google Ads
account and say you know show me people
with usually let's say your conversion
rates 2% meaning every 50 visitors
should convert so you can make rule that
says all right every hundred visitors
with no conversions let's just block
them but it takes a hundred visitors the
the end and that's the easy way to do it
it's right in the interface is easy to
select the the apps or videos or
websites in the interface and need to
exclude them what it's not going to do
is caught the low quality publishers
when there are only at thirty or forty
clicks so the other way you can see this
data in Google Analytics with bounce
rates paid with bounce rates pageviews
time on site etc also included so will
often make a filter in in Google
Analytics saying time on site is zero or
bounce is you know 90 percent or higher
and visitors is usually about 20 25 or
higher and block those pretty fast
because if you have 25 visitors and it's
a hotter percent bounce rate that's
usually an indication of a low-quality
site such usually the the easiest way to
do it i'm ii if on this screen may click
over to exclusions tab one of the
options is apps and you could block app
categories for mo
nann app install campaigns mobile apps
don't convert with the exception of
Google Drive and Gmail and and some
Google owned properties so you can often
go into the app category and block
bottom very quickly now some people do
okay on apps especially app installs so
you know don't just do that always by
default but that's all the way to get
rid of a lot of app traffic before you
start advertising - does it make sense
to count view-through conversions for
display or remarketing campaign they
sort of play a role in helping people
remember to come back and make a
purchase on your site but this really
helped the countess that's so view
through is a philosophy not a cilium
marketing tactic so just work for
everyone your knowledge a view through
means someone saw your ad on site a
didn't click on it didn't again with it
and later on went to your site through
some other means and converted do you
give value to the impression that the
user did not interact with and so view
throughs are treated so differently
across across companies Coke and Pepsi
and the big brands that they they want
the ad view as much as the click they
want to count that a lot of performance
marketers are like you didn't engage we
don't know if you even looked at it and
they will discount that so it does it
help the credibility a little bit when
Google made an oppression 50% of the ad
was displayed for I believe it's one
second or longer maybe it's three
seconds longer one second or longer so
but but if only half the ads displayed
then it still counts as an impression do
you count that as a view through and so
that's really a marketing philosophy
question that is not necessarily
answered with data I've never seen
anyone answer that question with data
it's always been on how we do is kind of
like attribution it's a philosophy not
solely a data set how long should you
wait after creating a new display
campaign before analyzing his
performance um that's a traffic question
right so if you're if you get a thousand
clicks in the first two days you should
analyze it if you get ten clicks in the
first two days you should just let it
run for a little bit generally we're
going to look at it the next day or two
just to make sure the the traffic looks
right the sights were being shown then
we're going to flip are the demographics
make sure the demographics seem to match
up correctly and that's not initially
isn't really there to say oh we need
your realtor or whatever it's really
there to make sure we didn't a do
something stupid and and you know forget
to add an exclusion or whatever and make
sure the quality looks right but it's
probably going to be one to two weeks
the minimum before we make major changes
so we wanted to breathe a little bit get
a chance to do stuff so usually a week
or two before anything drastic Stahn in
remarketing is it possible to exclude
certain audiences for example to show
and add to all visitors who visited your
homepage except for those who also
visited a specific page for registered
users set yes yes so when you go to the
audiences right so you'll also have
negative audiences so you would add your
targeting is all visitors your exclusion
is people who went to this page so now
you're showing an ad to everyone who did
not go to that page so just like
keywords can be positive and negative an
audience could be positive or negative
marketing ads no it's the same CPC
auction system same big options are
there two CPA bidding ECBC CPC whatnot
so overall the way ad rank and all this
stuff is calculated the exact same right
what about managed placements what do
they allow advertisers to do sure so if
we if we have this data here on the
screen and we look at the placements tab
instead it would be blank by default if
we take one of these sites and we make
it 8 min its placements
meaning we're ad showed means we
targeted our ads off of some criteria an
audience or whatnot and that's where ad
got displayed a placement is when we
specifically state I want to be on that
site so if you make an ad group with a
placement and an ad right that's
basically saying show my ads all you
want to but only on this website you can
set a bid for that placement if here
we're tricking our ads off of audiences
but if we add a placement then a
placement becomes a bid modifier or we
could say show my ads anymore base for
my audience list but if they're on this
site raise or lower my bed now that
would be their default way to add it you
could make it in your targeting right
the beat is the and or operator right
observation or targeting if we added a
placement as targeting which would be a
mistake for most for through marketing
we're saying only show my ad on that
website to this audience so it's usually
with when you're triggering ads off of
audiences and you add a placement you
want to add the placement as observation
meaning I want to see the stats I want
to raise all my bids but I don't want to
target only on that site if we only want
to add showing on a site they make a new
ad group make an ad only ad that website
and now you're showing ads only on that
specific site someone's asking should
you use accelerated delivery for
high-value audiences of remarketing or
try bidding strategies such as maximize
clicks for those high-value audiences
I will accelerate a delivery means
Google's going to serve the ad as fast
as possible as opposed to standard
medieval server throughout the day if
you have a budget you're never hitting
and you just want to make sure the ad
shows as much as possible accelerate is
great if you have a budget you're always
hitting then you generally want to use
standard to even up the ad display if
it's a high-value audience I I might
start when we first add the audience
we might use max clicks because we want
as a lot of data to evaluate and then
decide how we want to tweak the campaign
as a long-term strategy
I don't like max clicks because Google
doesn't care about the quality so you're
saying it's a high value audience but
they just want the most clicks possible
but it's a high value because it
converts well meaning it has a low CPA
usually so you're generally better off
once you have enough data the system can
kick in using a CPA bid based upon what
your value of that audience truly is and
not what Google just spend the money
right here's a quick one is there any
way to show GDL ads based on app usage
behavior instead of web visits behavior
if you are using fire I'm not an app
expert apps are a little different if
you're using firebase then fire based
data I believe can be employed can also
be imported into Google ads so you would
instead of defining your data in GA you
define your data in firebase which is an
analytic system for apps for the rest of
our users here and then in in and Google
Ads you cancel the remarketing ads off
of gdn based on the firebase on
behaviors right Brad what's your opinion
of the new discovery ads that Google in
laws at the Google marketing live show I
don't know so the discovery ads are our
app if you're an Android user and you've
got a pixel phone and you swipe left
meaning you're going to see that feed
that Google gives you articles that
thinks you should be reading me I'm
going to put ads in them they're called
discovery ads what what we don't add
some of the debate is Ford have looked
decent for large retailers and for
people again top of funnel somewhere on
the phones of direction but when we're
talking top a funnel
they'll probably be useful
I've seen some good data for retailers
introducing a spring and summer wardrobe
collections but again that's you know
showing a you know we're May season
we're going to start showing off here's
what we're going to sell the summer and
there's good results from a small
business standpoint I initially don't
have high hopes unless there's some real
specific targeting Google's can allow on
top of it which is still to be seen how
someone that works once it leaves beta
plug this one beta good results with
large companies not so with small ones
but have half hopes it'll be another
inventory source which types of image
ads achieve the best results do static
JPEG ads or removing gif or other types
of ads perform better
usually html5 that have some movement to
them because they attract the I get
better click-through rates now that
doesn't mean the conversion rates any
better right conversion rates user don't
change that much static ad versus a
dynamic ad but click the rates
definitely change there's no question
about it great is a display campaign
optimizer worth trying does it make a
difference i I have seen 24 campaigns
that use display campaign optimizer to
did had good results okay so alright I
can't say completely it's not worth
trying because two were good results and
one very surprisingly good results the
first one was for company who had a 10
percent conversion rate on display was
over 10,000 clicks and 0 conversions so
that was my introduction and it's gotten
a little better than that but not a huge
amount yeah if you use smart shopping
will it take impressions and clicks from
your remarketing campaign yes it also
does remarketing as well yes smart shot
oh this is the biggest so with smart
shopping Google will serve your out
across search and display
I've seen some good results with smart
shopping so I don't want to knock the
system here but the biggest issue that
we run into is that the company had a
really good remarketing set up and the
smart shopping was not attracting new
users it was really cannibalizing the
remarketing and the total sales
especially new sales
um decreased I've seen that several
times but I've also seen some small
companies use smart shopping incredibly
well and if they didn't have that
sophisticated of remarketing set up
there was no problem but if you've got
really good remarketing campaigns
I watched my shopping closely to see if
they start dropping and you need to
switch budget to the smart or if your
new customer acquisition drops like
often shoppings new customer remarketing
is returning customers at times so
you're going to want to watch that
balance right that's the same as like
what do you think of smart display
campaigns is that the same question or
yeah one knows what they're terrible
what I've seen so far again kind of like
DCO I've seen a couple good ones and
primarily really poor ones okay thank
you very much and thank you everyone for
your questions this has been a quite a
lively session here I just want to say
thank you again Brad for joining us oh
thank you for hosting us and keeping us
moving along my pleasure and thank you
everyone again
and we'll see you next time
[Music]